hello guys I'm Tyler posy and I'm here
with BuzzFeed and I am going to be
reading your thirst tweets just like
Daniel Radcliffe I thought thirst was
just to get attention but uh now I know
that there's something different and I'm
very
excited not to be horny on the main like
ever but I need Tyler posie to kiss me
on the forehead it's adorable I get a
little horny getting kiss on the
forehead too so I understand Tyler posie
saving the world with one only fans post
at a time I appreciate that I'm a huge
advocate in saving the world and wanting
to just better this place you know in a
very fun way and so that's uh that's
that's what I'm doing I didn't think of
it as big as saving the world but hell
yeah I'm game Tyler posie hot as [__]
Daddy not quite a daddy yet who knows
though you never know I've been around
great actor nice human being that's what
you think uh his smile
though thank you very much underrated
kind of I love that I love him don't at
me what the hell hell does that mean
these are all very nice I think we're I
think we're going up from thirsty to
very thirsty Tyler Posey's thighs give
me the will to live really I've never
heard that before I've never been
complimented on my thighs I guess they
are substantial I don't work on them
ever I just I just poop a lot so maybe
all the time on the toilet I want to
bake cupcakes with Tyler posie but at
the same time I want him to lick the
frosting off of my body I do have quite
the sweet tooth so I've probably done
that before I've licked frosting off of
my own body life goal you use Tyler's
butt as a pillow and just take a little
nap forever and ever uh I've heard that
is actually awesome and I've heard it
from my puppies say what you want but if
Tyler posy dropped an only fans I'd
instantly subscribe I have been sing for
that man since I was like 14 well you're
in luck because I did drop an only fans
and I have no idea what sing means so
thank you I appreciate it and go
subscribe I wish Tyler posy was on top
of me that's still kind of pretty sweet
like missionary isn't uh isn't too crazy
so I can get down with that Tyler posie
spit in my mouth
challenge okay cool I'm in uh my friends
and I have done that before and it
doesn't turn out the way that you would
want I would pay actual money to let
Tyler posie punch me oh my God hey man
fetishes are real but where where in the
face in the butt I'm down for it all
Tyler posie please bite my ass cheek um
sure yeah why not actually I don't know
buts can be kind of uh mysterious like I
don't know if that's the next step to
this BuzzFeed challenge I'm just reading
The Thirst tweets and then I actually
have to act on them but since you ask
nicely give it a shot I would let Tyler
posy snap my spine in two for all
eternity what the hell does that mean in
other news I would let Tyler posie liter
literally destroy me and tear me into
shreds is that a Teen Wolf reference CU
I was a werewolf and I did tear people
to shreds every now and then so I do
know how to do that Tyler posie could
slap me in the face with his dick and
knock out two of my teeth and I would
just swallow them happily well I
wouldn't want you to do that the Tooth
Fairy is is real you can get some good
money for that teeth but I appreciate it
pretty hot Tyler puy with facial hair
makes the busy go
wild what the [__] is the busy oh busy
but I had no idea sorry I was
pronouncing it wrong now I know yeah I
get it Tyler posie is so hot my busy
sneezed wait what how your butt
sneezed maybe just look at me when
you're on the toilet so that nothing bad
happens I am a hole for Tyler posie only
oh my God it's very sweet it's like
saving yourself from Marriage there's
something really funny about that
sentence I've never heard those words
put together that way before thank you
BuzzFeed for allowing me to read my
thirst tweets that was uh a much needed
boost of morale and I appreciate
everybody out there that is thirsty for
me I have a new movie coming out called
alone it's going to be on digital
October 16th and you get to see my butt
in
it
[Music]
in